Traduttore: Elena Montrasio
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Che cosa vuol dire essere alla guida
di una missione scientifica in Antartide?
La base di ricerca
internazionale "Concordia"
si trova in cima alla calotta polare.
È un luogo estremamente remoto:
si trova a 1.200 km
dalle basi sulla costa
che le forniscono un supporto logistico.
E le condizioni di vita sono estreme:
siamo a 4.000 metri di altitudine.
E la temperatura, in estate,
è di - 50 gradi centigradi;
e in inverno scende
sotto gli 80 gradi sotto zero.
La "Prince Elizabeth Station",
dove mi trovo adesso, invece,
è una base belga.
Si trova dalla parte dell'Antartide
che si affaccia sul Sudafrica,
ed è il primo edificio
a emissioni zero dell'Antartide.
I progetti da realizzare sono molti:
oltre ai carotaggi sul ghiaccio,
ci sono le misurazioni in quota,
gli strumenti da installare
che permettono, anche,
di campionare l'area a varie altezze;
organizzare le spedizioni alla costa,
per studiare l'ice shelf;
i telescopi da installare,
per cercare pianeti extrasolari:
la neve da sciogliere,
per catturare i micro meteoriti;
strumenti da installare
per studiare le interazioni terra-sole
e prevenire le tempeste solari,
che possono essere devastanti
per un telescopio in orbita nello spazio,
e poi, naturalmente,
c'è una base da gestire
e le manutenzioni da fare,
in qualsiasi condizione.
Questo sulla maschera
è il mio respiro congelato.
Le competenze da mettere in gioco,
in questo genere di missioni,
sono moltissime,
e le risorse decisamente limitate.
Il gruppo è formato
da specialisti di ogni genere,
e nello stesso team ti puoi trovare:
un ex militare che è stato, per anni,
responsabile della sala macchine
di un sommergibile,
un ricercatore celebre per essere stato
il precursore nello sviluppo
dei modelli climatici,
l'ex cuoco di una famosa
star hollywoodiana,
un incursore esperto di arti marziali,
un ex ingegnere della Formula 1,
un pilota canadese e un esploratore.
Ma è incredibile che sia qui.
Insomma, il gruppo è evidentemente
multiculturale, multidisciplinare
e soprattutto composto da individui
dalle personalità più disparate.
L'Antartide è il regno dell'incertezza:
la natura è forte, le nostre conoscenze
sono ancora molto limitate
e la logistica di una missione
è estremamente complessa.
Essere alla guida di un progetto
che si vuole realizzare
nell'estrema incertezza
significa molto di più
che navigare a vista.
Vuol dire avere molti scopi,
poco tempo, risorse limitate
e una situazione da considerare
costantemente con attenzione,
perché gli imprevisti drammatici
sono sempre in agguato
e le nostre azioni devono essere
tempestive, precise e adattive.
E a pensarci meglio, essere alla guida
di una missione scientifica in Antartide
è come essere il capitano
di una nave di pirati
che viaggia senza motore
in mezzo al mare in tempesta.
(Applausi)
In effetti,
il capitano di una nave dei pirati
che viaggia in mezzo al mare in tempesta -
io lo so, ora tra voi c'è qualcuno
che si sta domandando:
meno 50 gradi: che freddo!
4.000 metri di altitudine,
la mancanza d'aria,
una base da gestire, mille problemi,
e un ambiente estremamente pericoloso.
Perché vai in Antartide?
Beh, intanto dovete sapere
che esiste una malattia
che è il mal d'Antartide,
che è una specie di mal d'Africa.
E chi è stato in Antartide
per la prima volta,
poi inevitabilmente ci vuole tornare.
Certo, certi paesaggi
fai un po' fatica a dimenticarteli:
paesaggi come questo, le dry valley,
che sono una zona
dell'Antartide talmente arida
che non si forma neppure il ghiaccio.
E poi ci vivono
delle creature straordinarie:
qui vivono dei licheni
che sono in grado di arrestare
i loro processi vitali
quando le condizioni di vita
sono troppo estreme.
Ma non vanno in letargo:
mettono, letteralmente,
la loro vita in pausa.
E poi la riprendono,
quando le condizioni sono più gradevoli.
Ma il mal d'Antartide
è fatto di un sacco di cose:
ci sono gli incontri
con le persone, la sfida,
la bellezza di fare un progetto comune,
la convivenza, e forse la convivenza
non è la prima cosa a cui pensi,
quando pensi con nostalgia all'Antartide.
Però, tra i vari aspetti
che ci spingono a tornare
questa sera vi voglio parlare
di uno in particolare,
ed è il fatto che l'Antartide
ci espone continuamente,
ma continuamente, all'incertezza.
E questa cosa fa sì
che la nostra consapevolezza
della complessità di cui è fatto il mondo
aumenti.
È una specie di palestra,
una palestra di complessità.
Per esempio, una delle caratteristiche
che si sviluppano in Antartide
è la resilienza.
La resilienza, lo sapete,
è una proprietà naturale
di tutti gli esseri viventi.
In pratica, un essere vivente
che perde la resilienza
difficilmente riesce a sopravvivere.
E ho trovato questa definizione:
sono due ricercatori che hanno dedicato
un intero volume alla resilienza,
e la definiscono così:
la capacità di un sistema,
di un'impresa, di una persona,
di mantenere il suo scopo principale,
e la sua integrità,
di fronte a circostanze
drasticamente mutate.
In pratica, a livello psicologico
è la capacità di adattarsi
alle trasformazioni mentre si trasformano.
In pratica, è la capacità
di saper trasformare le situazioni,
e trasformare anche noi stessi,
pur rimanendo radicati,
conservando il nostro centro.
Un po' come un albero che,
in mezzo alla turbolenza della tempesta,
si piega ma non si spezza.
Ecco, credo che la resilienza
sia un elemento veramente importante.
Perché in Antartide ti trovi sempre
in balia dell'incertezza.
E all'inizio è veramente difficile
perché le spedizioni
non si organizzano più come una volta,
quando ai tempi
di Shackleton, per esempio,
si sentivano i discorsi dei balenieri
per indirizzare il percorso della nave:
oggi siamo abituati
ad avere tutto sotto controllo,
per esempio,
anche una spedizione in Antartide
può far affidamento
sulle tecnologie più sofisticate,
come le immagini satellitari
con le quali possiamo vedere, per esempio,
l'andamento del pack in mezzo al mare,
o i crepacci in tempo reale.
Però, anche se ci prepariamo,
anche se utilizziamo tutte le tecnologie
che abbiamo a disposizione,
alla fine, in Antartide
succede sempre qualcosa di inaspettato.
Sempre qualcosa che poi scatena
tutta una serie di eventi a catena,
e distrugge tutti i nostri piani,
non importa se li abbiamo
fatti perfettamente.
Ed è un'esperienza
abbastanza scioccante.
Come per esempio due anni fa:
mi trovavo alla base "Concordia",
è la base che si trova
in cima alla calotta polare,
è la base dove sono stata più spesso,
dove ho più spesso fatto
il capo spedizione.
E quell'anno sembrava
che tutto andasse secondo i nostri piani.
Stavamo aspettando il rifornimento
di carburante dalla costa.
Di solito, per sicurezza,
abbiamo una riserva di carburante
che ci garantisce, ovviamente,
di avere un'autonomia per un anno:
però quell'anno, per la prima volta
da quando è stata costruita la base,
non l'avevamo, perché l'anno precedente
avevamo deciso di dare
tutta la nostra scorta
a un grande progetto di ricerca.
Era un campionamento di ghiaccio,
fatto con una traversa
che doveva attraversare il plateau.
Ma avevamo calcolato tutti i rischi:
e del resto, poi, a giorni
sarebbe arrivata la nostra nave,
avrebbe attraccato alla costa
poi il carburante sarebbe arrivato a noi,
come avveniva effettivamente
da 15 anni, tutti gli anni.
Invece, in quei giorni, una nave russa
che non c'entrava niente con noi,
che si trovava a più
di 1.300 km di distanza,
lancia un sos.
E questo evento si è scatenato su di noi
come il battito d'ali di una farfalla
che scatena un uragano
dall'altra parte del mondo.
Perché la nostra nave
è stata richiamata in soccorso,
e quando l'emergenza è finita,
dopo 14 giorni,
e fortunatamente, tutti i passeggeri
sono stati tratti in salvo,
e la nostra nave ha cercato
di fare rotta, di nuovo,
verso la base francese
che la stava aspettando,
questa è la situazione che ha trovato.
Il pallino rosso
indica la posizione della nave,
quello giallo quello
della base francese, in cui era attesa.
In mezzo c'erano 100 km di pack.
Una situazione che i francesi
di quella base
non avevano mai visto
in 50 anni di spedizione.
Noi, a Concordia,
siamo rimasti senza carburante
per tutta la stagione.
E ovviamente, tutta
la nostra pianificazione,
tutto il nostro lavoro di un anno
è andato in fumo.
Abbiamo dovuto riorganizzarci
con quello che avevamo,
e rifare tutto da capo.
Ecco, a me sembra che l'Antartide
assomigli molto alla vita,
molto di più delle nostre
esperienze urbane,
perché anche nella vita ci capita
che facciamo i piani, ci organizziamo,
pensiamo tutti gli scenari possibili,
cominciamo a costruire,
e poi, all'improvviso,
accade l'inaspettato,
qualcosa che manda tutto all'aria.
E dobbiamo riorganizzarci
con quello che abbiamo.
Effettivamente è un'esperienza scioccante,
ma è più scioccante quando sei
il capo spedizione in Antartide,
perché lì hai la responsabilità
anche di tutti gli altri.
E all'inizio confesso
che è stata abbastanza dura,
è stato un po' stressante.
Solo che dopo un po'
ho cominciato a rendermi conto
che avevo familiarizzato
con questa incertezza, con l'imprevisto.
E che avevo capito qualcosa
magari un qualcosa di più
sulla complessità del mondo.
Per esempio, mi ero accorta
di essere resiliente.
Quella di cui vi parlo
è la resilienza mentale.
Che cos'è?
In realtà è un concetto molto complesso,
ed è molto difficile definirlo,
chiuderlo in una definizione:
però io ho pensato di sintetizzarlo
in tre elementi fondamentali.
Il primo è la capacità
di leggere le trasformazioni.
Perché si sa: in natura tutto cambia,
e magari siamo noi che ci illudiamo
che le cose siano sempre le stesse.
E allora bisogna imparare a leggere
quelli che si chiamano i segnali deboli,
cioè quei segnali che stanno nel presente
e che hanno in sé
un embrione del futuro che verrà.
E in Antartide, questo è obbligatorio.
E allora abbiamo imparato
a stare sempre un po' in allerta,
anche quando la situazione
è la più tranquilla possibile.
Sapete, come fanno gli animali,
che si rilassano, sembra
che si stiano godendo il momento,
ma sono sempre pronti
a drizzare le orecchie,
sempre pronti a scattare
se qualcosa non va.
E qui veniamo al secondo punto:
la capacità di reagire rapidamente,
senza nascondersi dietro alibi,
senza stare a pensare
a quello che sarebbe dovuto essere.
E questo ci serve
per la nostra lucidità mentale,
perché noi, purtroppo,
non possiamo fare come i licheni,
e mettere la nostra vita in pausa
se qualcosa non va.
Effettivamente lo stanno studiando,
ma per ora bisogna aspettare.
E dobbiamo agire rapidamente.
E poi c'è il terzo elemento,
che è la capacità di esplorare
e ricombinare con creatività
le cose che abbiamo trovato
lungo il cammino
della nostra esplorazione.
Esplorare per me è fondamentale.
E lo so, non è facile,
perché, per esplorare,
bisogna uscire dalla "comfort zone".
Bisogna mettersi in gioco,
bisogna aprirsi,
bisogna mettersi in dubbio.
E delle volte,
può essere anche pericoloso.
Però, esplorando ci si espone
ai nuovi punti di vista,
alle nuove esperienze,
a nuove emozioni, nuove idee.
E questo è importante,
perché crea diversità dentro di noi.
Crea risorse.
E quelle risorse ci saranno molto utili
quando la nostra zona di comfort
si starà trasformando,
si starà evolvendo in qualcos'altro.
E allora dovremo affrontare un problema,
e lì attingeremo a quelle risorse
che abbiamo sviluppato
nella nostra esplorazione.
E dovremmo ricombinarli in modo creativo,
per trovare una soluzione
al problema che dobbiamo affrontare.
Magari anche un problema
che non si era mai visto.
Questa foto è la foto
della mia ultima spedizione
alla Princess Elizabeth Station,
dell'anno scorso.
Anche in quel caso ero il capospedizione,
e forse è la spedizione più difficile
che ho dovuto affrontare.
Perché, quando siamo arrivati,
ci siamo accorti
che la nostra base
era stata sabotata e saccheggiata.
Qualcuno aveva organizzato
una spedizione parallela,
e aveva portato via
gran parte della nostra attrezzatura.
Tra cui tutta la scorta di cibo,
e gran parte dell'attrezzatura
dell'infermeria.
Allora, vi confesso,
ho pensato davvero che fosse finita.
E soprattutto, mi sono stupita.
E pensavo che in 12 anni
di esperienza in Antartide
mi fossi abituata anche a essere stupita:
ma questa non me la sarei mai immaginata.
Però, poi, ho fatto
una riunione con il mio team,
abbiamo analizzato le risorse
che ci erano rimaste,
incluse le competenze
che avevamo all'interno del team.
E abbiamo deciso
che non era ancora arrivato
il momento di mollare.
E così, oltre che una spedizione
di quattro mesi
in condizioni veramente molto difficili,
siamo riusciti a portare a termine
tutti i programmi di ricerca.
E in particolare, ce n'è stato uno
che si è trasformato nel classico problema
che diventa un'opportunità.
Perché tra le varie modifiche
che abbiamo fatto,
abbiamo fatto una modifica
alla pianificazione di ricerca
e abbiamo accorpato
due programmi scientifici
che inizialmente
dovevano lavorare separatamente.
E quella contaminazione
si è rivelata molto efficace.
Per cui i ricercatori
hanno trovato dei risultati di ricerca
molto più interessanti insieme,
che se avessero lavorato separatamente.
E allora, tutto questo
per dire che, secondo me,
la capacità di affrontare l'incertezza,
di non perdersi d'animo,
di sapere che il mondo è complesso
e di essere resilienti
sono veramente competenze fondamentali,
soprattutto in questo momento storico:
viviamo in un mondo
che è sempre più complesso
ed è sempre più incerto.
E sviluppare competenze
come la resilienza è fondamentale.
E così, io sto scommettendo su questo:
in questo momento sto lavorando,
unendo lo studio del pensiero complesso
alle esperienze di vita in Antartide.
E li sto portando nelle aziende,
nelle organizzazioni
e al contatto quotidiano delle persone.
Perché essere resilienti, per esempio,
significa sapere che,
anche se la situazione fuori
si sta trasformando in un modo
che sembra caotico,
tu hai un'altra scelta,
oltre che subirla perché non sai
dove sta andando la situazione.
Puoi trasformare quella situazione,
oppure puoi trasformare te stesso
pur rimanendo ancorato al tuo centro.
E credo che queste competenze
siano veramente importanti
per il nostro futuro,
perché sono fondamentali
per sentirci attori del nostro futuro,
che è quello che noi costruiamo
tutti i giorni con le nostre scelte.
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)